[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen so wie heute und damals sind
herzlich willkommen zu diesem neuen
video ich habe heute einen special guest
und 2 jonas als gut 90 euro freuen
wir sind hier nämlich gerade in
oberstdorf an der bayerischen grenze zu
österreich tatsächlich in den alpen also
wir haben auch eine super schöne
aussicht hier liegt auch dick schnee
also ist jetzt ein bisschen geschmolzen
deswegen haben wir die chancen noch
genutzt um dieses video zu drehen dann
zwar haben wir beide insgesamt jetzt so
ich bin hier noch viel sehr unangenehme
fragen für den anderen rausgesucht und
entweder man beantwortet die oder man
springt im schnitt haben wir schon
wieder für jonas gedreht war wirklich
sehr krank und erhalten haben wir vielen
übrigens noch 9000 verboten dann habe
ich die zwei 2,77 millionen also leicht
das lohnt sich auf jeden fall war jonas
auf vorbeizuschauen
du bist schon sehr schnell gelernt und
ich auch ja alles klar dann würde ich
sagen mal gucken was wir heute die leute
wissen dann keine freunde bescheid dass
wir vorhin hat die marie heißt ja auch
schon ein paar mal betrogen hast warum
habe ich die bedrohung so muss eine
fangfrage aber du reagierst relativ hat
sich das jetzt hat mich immer okay aber
ich hab' ich hab euch ein paar fragen
dazu später noch ausgesucht und schon
fängt ja schnick schnack schnuck also
wir müssen halt wirklich oberkörper frei
und schnee springen nur mit dieser
kurzen hose und natürlich auch ohne
schuhe also mit also ich würde ohne füße
das ganze machen aber alles offen damit
fließen dann muss es auch mit füßen
machen ich mache ja ich gehe auf jeden
fall raus ich gehe nur bei und
nichtkunden ich habe schon so was hab
ich kein bock hätte wenn du die frage
wenn du auf die frage beantwortet was
habe ich noch nicht mal so dass nämlich
eine neue okay also auf welche auf
welche instagram welche instagram retten
das letzte weg mache ich ohne scheiß
nicht immer andere also ehrlich ich gehe
nicht auf instagram suchen da irgendwas
raus ohne scheiß [ __ ] werden
sorry so ja ich sage nicht dass das
jetzt irgendwie es muss jetzt deine
schwester sein oder so sagen ich gehe
davon aus dass können ja auch das könnte
auch
berühmte schauspielerin sein oder etwas
in diese richtung ohne witz oder
das mache ich nicht also ganz gerne
angeführt die fensterrahmen so was du
aber du machst du jetzt schon mal mörder
alex wird deswegen habe er dazu keine
frage stellen dann muss ich alle meine
fragen da rausnehmen
also wie würdest du deine eigenen hohen
beschreiben männlich ist keine
beschreibung
natürlich weiß das denn für die
beschreibung jeder hoben das männliche
ego ist keine beschreibung
also ich will dass du auch die
konsistenz ein gehst auf die behaarung
auch die größe auf die irgendwo auch auf
die sinnhaftigkeit auf die produktivität
ich möchte das für die sache und ein
dicker wie kommt man auf diese frage wir
haben wirklich ein externer ein bisschen
durch ein bisschen ein guter morgen ja
es also es ist ja halt menschlich so
dass die sich auch die konsistenz kann
sich verändern von haar zu weich gesetzt
sich allgemeine sollst deinen
beschreiben jaha zu weich kann sich halt
je nach temperaturen zu ändern wenn ich
irgendwie im kalten wasser wende
wirklich wenn du immer nur mit den
händen weil die größe im verein gehen
müsstest das jetzt werden wahrscheinlich
relativ klein
ok alex
ich werde nicht mehr verheimlichen buchs
klippen kommt nach vorne
ja
kein
[Musik]
meine füße
das ist echt kalt schon warum hast hier
im schnee ach so ja ich wollte meine
wohnung nicht vor hundert tausend leuten
im internet beschreiben das nicht weil
ich gerade rum
die leute die jetzt in die kommentare
schreiben das ist so viel ihr seid so
pervers seid ihr verrückt ich sag immer
dazu und das ist tatsächlich so als
halte wagen war mit im schnitt also ja
es geht ja darum dass wir in anderen
fragen stellen damit er in den schnee
geht also komplett abgefuckte fragen und
das sind so sachen ganz ehrlich und
freunden rumhängen dann aber also kann
man arbeitet sich über die 1
wir machen das doch gestern gefragt und
er hat sie mir auch gezeigt deswegen
kann ich auch die antwort okay meinte
welche fragen ich noch sonst mit
reingenommen haben aber die stelle ich
bin ich war das wäre zu langweilig wie
viel ist ein outfit wert darstellt
naja ich leute die halt nur was gutes
tun weißt du hast du schon mal
erotischen fotos von dir gemacht falls
ja wie also beschreibt haben wir noch
genug
ok kann ich ja wirklich beantworten ich
in den schnee gab erotische fotos von
mir gemacht ich habe ich habe fotos von
mir gemacht vom spiegel
ja und ich habe auch schon fotos gemacht
quasi aus der theorie von mir von
gewissen aber das nicht fast jeder schon
gemacht also ich habe so etwas noch
nicht mal dann muss aber verdammt wo
sich sein dass man also ich kann das
jetzt auch nicht regeln aber ich habe
das manchmal darf ist auf gar keinen
fall verständlich versetzt und hält man
das anders und auf seinem handy behalten
am besten macht man das stelle ich mir
so vor mit so einer wie heißen die diese
kann manuell war dass ihr auskommen
dieses bild mit einer polaroid-kamera
weil dann ist es noch nicht
digitalisiert er war
du hast du kannst es der person
übergeben das vollautomatische also
irgendwie newsletter voll geil
eigentlich aber solange mein gesicht
nicht drauf es ist doch erst mal mein
gesicht
hätte ich so lange aber ja und dann hast
du das verschiebt auch also ich habe mit
gesicht habe ich nie verschickt mit
gesicht habe ich verschenkt ich habe
dass ich an dem gerät geschickt
ich habe das nur an eine gewisse ex
freundin geschenkt und die hat jetzt die
fotos neuen kann mich erpressen
das ist das problem das ist die frage
aber ist beruht auf gegenseitigkeit gut
kommen wir da zunächst die frage was
dann würde ich gern von dir wissen wie
viel geld wird es in diesem monat schon
durch dass du selber verdient hast
einfach die alisa monat war eigentlich
ganz gut bei mir war ich hatte diesen
monat am meisten placement und mit dem
user auch ganz cool weil die züge müssen
uns gut glaube ich ja jetzt bis jetzt
oder wie weil ich an mein geld ein
youtube krieg zum beispiel immer am 28
war da was diesen monat noch kriege ja
was insgesamt zu krieg seien ungefähr
dann bringen wir jetzt hier von 500 euro
schon 2000 euro ich kann es nicht sagen
35.000 oder so was sagte jonas 11 jeden
monat den streiks dreifachen
wahrscheinlich okay aber ist ja also es
ist auch ein meister monate also klar
wir uns kurz bodenständigkeit hier
gezeigt wir sitzen ja gerade nicht einem
amg oder sonst irgendwas wir sitzen in
einem skoda aber leute ganz wichtig zu
sagen es ist ja der bruttoverdienst lang
geht ihr noch einige stadtteile wird
machen steuerfahnder also ich kann nicht
mein spiel
also dass schon jetzt nächste nebenbei
spielte ja dann ist es eigentlich ja
auch darüber reden kann ich witzig uns
eigentlich oder so auf marin kann also
ich finde das auch jetzt noch nicht im
eigentlich muss ich sagen dann welche
drogen hast du alles schon ausprobiert
oder war also zählt einfach mal auf ob
du schon irgendwas anderes ausprobieren
das außer alkohol ist alles raushauen
wie sie für mich wirklich okay schon
wieder crack heroin
das war tatsächlich ist aus nicht
ausschließlich magna noch nie irgendwie
mal in den dann hochregal war ein
argument das auch schon so lange
das ist schon über zwei jahre her und
sonst immer nur alkohol ja nie irgendwie
mal was anderes probiert so gut was gibt
so eine sache
die würde ich irgendwann gerne noch mal
ausprobieren für die experience muss man
nicht machen da es keinen fall aber also
theoretisch sogar zwei sachen die ich
einfach mal auch sein würde aber es ist
nicht gut aber ich finde ich finde ich
generell schon spannend natürlich ja so
irgendwas wie heißt es hallo hallo zug
herzig
sprachenlernen antigene drogen hat das
hellas day und sowas ja sowas nicht
gerne einmal ausprobieren aber ob das
wirklich keine ahnung also ich würde
niemals irgendwas machen um es dauerhaft
im leben oder so für jeden morgen erste
danke für diese relativ gute fragen
einer skala von 1 bis 10
wie gut ist der sex und maria veen auf
jeden fall ehrlich ja es richtig gut
habt ihr noch aktuell sehr regelmäßig
ist das war jetzt nicht die frage
scheiße ich hätte so noch andere
spannende fragen interessiert hätte dann
kann es ja gleich noch stehen ja mach
ich auch um eine frage wer mir
eingefallen die man mir stellen können
sie die hätte auch absolut 100% schnee
dings gewesen okay ja ja dieser fertig
natürlich nicht hengst immer noch sehr
an einer ex-freundin frage ist nun ein
freier aber es war nicht die frage
es war nicht die frage aber die
schnellen anfrage erkläre deine gefühle
wenn du an einer ex-freundin längst aber
real war also richtig ruhig was ihn
allerdings ab ich nicht das kann ich
vielleicht sogar auch beantworten und
wieder los du darfst du keine nachfragen
stellen ja gut dann aber du musst dich
hier aus führen jetzt das haus führen
also die gefühlslage wenn du darüber
über die situation allerdings war ich
weiß nicht wie sich das ausführen kann
ja muss einfach jetzt oder du gehst halt
weiß ich was zu hören willst genau ja
was ist also das was so wie es halt ist
eine krankheit im schnee aber wird eine
schnelle entscheidung weil wir müssen ja
auch die herren kommen also gefühlsmäßig
würde ich sagen es ist ein bisschen
trauer vielleicht noch und natürlich
gibt es auch momente in denen man wieder
zurück also an die sachen zurück denken
sie ist aber vor allem einfach irgendwie
also ausschließlich eigentlich nur
negative emotionen ist es ja auch keinen
genau also auch das ja es war ja
generell keine keine trennung guten
deswegen
vereint und hast richtig gehört schon
was ich gern wäre ich damit jetzt auch
nichts weiterbringt so weiter letzte
frage oder du bist ja dann muss also
mich würde mal interessieren beiden
kreisklassen verdrehtes zusammen wie oft
hatte und marina 68 einfach mal eine
absage
irgendwie wieder die dreh gefallen was
weiß ich das ist auch schon ein bisschen
her
insgesamt beiden ja keine ahnung so
fünfmal und sechsmal
ok man kann also ich frag mich dass wir
die räume waren eng aneinander
so hätte ich auch angst dass man hören
kann zustand zu stellen die ganze zeit
so wir uns in der tür zum badezimmer die
ganze zeit
ok ich hab' noch ein erzähler eine
krasse fantasie von dir die du noch nie
jemandem erzählt hast das kann's voller
krankheit betroffen
ich bin runde im schnee das ist eine
richtige killer fragen ja ja das und
jonas kommen ist für mein video bis nach
ganz hinten weiter weiterkommen einmal
bis zur scheune da hinten bis zur
scheune
jawohl und da immer drehen weiter weiter
weiter weiter weiter
ich wollte eigentlich auch recht gesagt
ich bin gerade daran bis dahin gefallen
das ist nicht nur ein sie sich hinein
ich wollte hier eigentlich abschließen
aber es hat nicht geklappt wie lange
hast du dich gefühlt man ich habe schon
bist du ganz hinten was gefilmt
naja ist kalt oder ist ein bisschen
schwer meine füße war auf jeden fall ein
spannendes lustiges video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen war mal was anderes
also ich mache ich normalerweise andere
videos wenn ja was schon lange kein
langes video wenn ihr gott hat auch weil
das überhaupt zu einem airport wir
machen das beste machen so einen kanal
zu sagen so aus wie sich unsere
unterliegen videos reicht
und die machen einfach ein durchgehender
damit okay leute das war's was du noch
unter teck auf jeden fall auch jonas
kann ab juni den kanal stehen 20.000
richtig spaß gemacht und wir fahren
jetzt los wir müssen das auto in
zweieinhalb stunden abgeben wichtig ist
auf jeden fall ich werde nackt einfach
ganz fans dafür eigentlich nicht also
hat rein